[MUSIC PLAYING]
FLORIE HUTCHINSON:
Thank you to Mike
and to Google for
inviting me in today
to talk about my
very personal journey
down the rabbit hole of emoji
over the last 18 months--
the sequence of
events which led me
to the creation of the
woman's blue flat shoe
and my subsequent conviction
in the power of emoji
to enrich the pop
cultural landscape
and simultaneously be a very
subtle catalyst for change.
As an emoji enthusiast,
it's great fun for me
to think about this
visual lexicon, which
has exploded, and more
importantly, where it's going.
However, it's very
much a new area for me.
Had someone told
me 18 months ago
that I would create an emoji
that would become a cause
celebre and be anointed
as a feminist symbol,
I genuinely would have chuckled.
And yet, here we are.
When I look at this little
emoji available on over 20
billion smart-connected
devices across the globe,
I see my worldview reflected
and represented in a small, yet
perfect little illustration.
That worldview is the product
of my twin occupations.
The first as a fiercely
committed mother
to four young daughters.
And the second as
a media strategist
within the arts
and culture sphere.
As a mother, I spent
a lot of time thinking
about early childhood language
acquisition and screen
time, literacy, and
implicit gender biases faced
by women in all age groups.
As an arts professional,
I have a profound belief
and deep conviction in
the knowledge produced
by artists and their
unparalleled ability
to tap into the zeitgeist
before many others do so.
I do also see the
world and experience it
through a very visual lens.
It is in that paradigm and
the combination of these two
occupations that led me
to this little emoji that
launched 1,000 thoughts.
Bear with me as I try
to tackle a few of them.
As I mentioned, I am
the mother to these four
formidable daughters
ranging from seven
years old to 10 weeks.
However stepping
back to spring 2017,
I was just beginning to
reemerge from the newborn vortex
as my third daughter--
the blonde--
started inching her way toward
sleeping through the night.
She had joined us
in November of 2016,
on election night no less, and
was our first US-born child.
By May 2017, my partner
and I had finally
arrived at that happy
equilibrium in the family
dynamic where one
of you following
the addition of a new child
is actually comfortable
being left alone with
all of your children.
And so on this glorious
weekend in May,
I tore my way through some
very unglamorous, but highly
practical Saturday
chores, mostly
related to the domestic sphere.
Our first stop was the
local grocery store.
Now keep in mind, we
all live in Palo Alto,
where the produce is incredible
and this presentation is
something of a visual feast.
Yet my Saturday morning
shopping in no way
resembles luxurious UX.
Quite the opposite, it's more
of a military-grade blitzkrieg
operation.
On this particular
day, as I grab
the shopping cart to wiz my
kids around the produce section,
I instructed our
two older girls,
who were five and
three at the time,
to sit down near the
book carousel area
at our local grocery store.
Yes, there are books
for children there.
And yes, my children
sat down on the floor
and read them while
I try and choose
our fruits and vegetables.
Now normally, this would
be done in lightning speed,
but that morning, our happy
chaos was abruptly interrupted.
The book that both of
my children had chosen
was this one--
"Polite as a Princess."
I tried-- albeit in
vain-- for a few seconds
in my sleep-deprived haze to
turn the carousel and look
for its male counterpart--
"Polite as a Prince."
It should come as no surprise
that it didn't exist.
It still doesn't.
So I remove the books from my
daughters' hands, placed them
in the cart, and made my
way to the checkout line,
while simultaneously
expressing my disappointment
with this book using
Disney's Instagram hashtag.
Next up, we cross the street
to our local baby boutique,
where on my punch
list was a desire
to replace my existing
baby carrier, which was now
five years old and
egregiously stained,
because surely the
design and the materials
had gone through some innovation
since I originally bought mine.
As I reviewed the new options--
and there were literally
20 boxes on the shelves--
I had an alarming realization.
Only one package among the
20 depicted a male figure
toting his child.
It was a Norwegian
brand called Stokke.
It seemed that only Norwegian
fathers carried their children.
Frustrated by this
visual reminder
that women are expected
to literally carry
the brunt of child-rearing
responsibilities,
I hot stepped out of the
store with my three daughters
and went home.
As a side note, this
very topic became
something of a rather viral
episode a few months ago,
which some of you
may have seen, when
Piers Morgan took to Twitter
and insulted Daniel Craig--
a.k.a.
Bond-- for toting his kid.
In a similar spirit,
"The Wall Street Journal"
recently published a huge
feature on male-focused
designed carriers displaying
such masculine motifs
as camouflage and
neutral color ways.
It would only be
later that night
as I was nursing the baby
while everyone was asleep
that the stiletto's appearance
became the emoji that broke
the proverbial camel's back.
I was sending a message
to a friend in Europe
when I typed the seemingly
innocuous word "shoe."
And it was the first
time that I noticed
that emoji autopopulated.
And this was what appeared.
And in it, I saw the
final visual reminder--
this time, in the
virtual universe--
of all the unrealistic
expectations
bestowed upon women.
How does one begin to unpack
the litany of thoughts
that entered my mind at 3:00
AM when I saw this symbol--
this small little
picture that said to me
that we, as women,
are expected to walk
the world in high heels?
I think this is a
great place to start.
This is a work by a hot young
artist-- male artist-- named
Torbjorn Rodland, who's
represented by David Kordansky
Gallery in Los Angeles.
In this singular image,
the stiletto evokes danger,
seduction, provocation with
more than a soupcon of pain.
It's a tool of power,
which women ought to own.
Yet this was my reality.
This photograph is by Vivian
Maier, who some of you
may have seen the documentary.
And it's very much like most
of her photographic oeuvre,
showing this woman
who was anonymously
shot without the consent
of the subject in the '70s.
This woman in Manhattan
is wearing that shoe,
and is literally
injured, and has even
gone to the lengths of
crafting a heel for her cast.
And so I began to ask
myself whether my aversion
to stilettos was simply a unique
byproduct of spending literally
the last eight years
either pregnant,
carrying a baby on my
torso, pushing a stroller,
or bending over while helping
a little person learn to walk.
In other words, was my mom
attire in the footwear category
an isolated experience?
The resounding answer
after weeks of research,
which would ultimately
inform my emoji proposal,
was no, it was not isolated.
I started looking at
the history of footwear.
And what I unearthed
very quickly
was that the red high heel
and all of its implications
that accompany it date
back at least 70 years
to the days of "Mad Men."
The following is a small
sampling of the vintage
as I unearthed.
I particularly liked
this one, which
is actually an editorial
from "The New Yorker"
magazine in the 1950s.
Can anyone guess who it is?
It's Andy Warhol.
Not only is it done by
Warhol, but the red high heel
is literally equated with
success for female workers
in New York City.
Interestingly, I actually
discovered this spread
on the Whitney's
Instagram stories
from their current major
Warhol retrospective--
the first in over 30 years.
Shifting my gaze from
historical ads and editorials,
I turned my eye to
the contemporary
and started examining
how footwear is used
to communicate to women today.
And what I found was that
we have made no progress.
In many ways, I think
it's actually worsened.
Here is an ad from the
breastfeeding lobbying group
in the UK, in which you can
save your money from formula
to be a yummier mummy.
Here's one from Clinique.
I would challenge to
ask where is the comfort
in the red stiletto?
In this GEICO ad,
women are literally
encouraged to switch
their insurance policy,
so they can famously save
and redeploy said savings
to the things they love--
red pumps.
Interestingly, the male
counterpart of this ad,
which appears in
men's magazines,
is a big hunk of steak.
In this one-- another
great export from the UK--
the National Health
Service equates
motherhood with the abandonment
of a very specific version
of femalehood.
Here, we have the TSA
espousing better convenience
at the airport while traveling.
Yet I would challenge that
the most inconvenient part
of removing shoes is
actually shoes with laces,
not the heel, plus I
don't know many women
who actually wear heels while
traipsing across the airport.
The US Postal Service equates
fashion with high heels
and suggests that neither
fashion nor the post office
rest on Sundays.
Zappos-- a category buster,
which I'll return to later
in the footwear space--
suggests that women
all love red stilettos.
Barclays, in urging financial
literacy and acumen,
again suggests that
those funds that you save
should be spent on shoes.
The newly-launched magazine,
which went viral earlier this
month and some of
you may have seen
because of a sensationalist
image of Rachel McAdams pumping
in designerwear,
has this tagline--
"bringing back the
woman stiletto."
I find it ironic given
the title of the magazine.
For Giving Tuesday,
Bruno Magli donated
100 pairs of these
burgundy suede stilettos.
They're named the Gala Pump.
Now, I would venture
to say that a woman who
is new to the job search
and interview process
should have one fewer
thing to be thinking about,
which is learning to walk
in six-inch stilettos.
Of course, we're here at Google,
and one of my very first places
when I went down that rabbit
hole was to look at Google Arts
and Culture.
This shoe is an item of footwear
intended to protect and comfort
the human foot while the wearer
is doing various activities.
Now I don't know about you,
but nothing about this shoe
made me think of
comfort or walking.
To Google's credit, within
24 hours of me Instagramming
it-- "come on Google.
You can do better."--
They changed it.
It's now a raggedy old boot.
This is a scent
that was recently
launched by Carolina Herrera.
And wait for it, it's
called Good Girl.
The text used to get women
to buy it says it all.
It's good to be bad, provocative
intent, lethal charisma,
seductive charisma,
and there's no escape.
It's about ruthless power.
Now that we spent some time
investigating how stilettos
are generally depicted and the
weighty expectations that they
carry with them as
a visual emblem,
I wanted to talk also about
my observations with emoji
specifically, which
have been formed
through the eyes of
my young children.
As I mentioned at the beginning,
I was very much an emoji novice
18 months ago.
Only the casual sort of
kiss-sending face or the heart
appeared in my text messaging.
Yet this all changed when my
children began attending school
and suddenly, emojis seemed
to be literally everywhere.
So let's talk about how
much my children love emoji
and how omnipresent they
are in their daily existence
because in many ways,
the impetus to create
my flat-shoe emoji
was one driven
by parental
responsibility and duty.
If my kids were going to be
using emoji and seeing them
repeatedly in their routines,
shouldn't I at least
try to create some
semblance of balance
to the three existing
high-heeled options that
existed.
There was apparel.
You can make
bracelets with emoji.
You can wear your
emoji to school.
You can keep your innermost
thoughts in an emoji diary.
And if you don't feel like
describing your emotions,
you can use the emoji stickers.
You can get National
Geographic to help you decode
the emoji language, literally.
At this point, I had accepted
that my children were
using emoji, not necessarily
as a language, but as
an expressive plaything.
So I turned to the
other world that I
know and love and occupy--
the arts.
And I started thinking about
how artists were engaging
with the subject matter.
And it became very
clear that they too
were questioning the
broader sentiment that emoji
were simple little playthings,
throwaways, a trend
to be dismissed and outgrown.
The original emoji set here,
which I'm sure many of you
know, seems like a really
good place to start.
Released exactly 20 years ago
in 1999 and including 176 emoji,
its acquisition
by MoMA last year
was certainly viewed as a
legitimizing watershed moment.
MoMA's collection in
New York is filled
with examples of
design innovations
that radically
altered our world.
So for emoji, including the
little red pixilated stiletto
next to the scissors
and the hamburger,
to become part of
that collection
was historically significant.
Now that institutional
backing was in place,
I was really curious about
how artists themselves
were dealing with emoji today.
I first came across
this image last August
via Mary Boone Gallery's
Instagram page.
It depicts the fist and
the painting-nail emoji.
And my curiosity,
as you can imagine,
was immediately piqued.
The work is by Derrick Adams,
a young African-American
multidisciplinary artist
based in Brooklyn, whom I've
been following for some time.
When I contacted the gallery a
few weeks ago for the purpose
of this presentation and to
learn more about this painting,
it emerged that is actually
part of a whole new body of work
which will be shown in
March entitled New Icons.
Through multiple layers
of CNC-applied paint
and also by hand,
Derek has purposely
mimicked the digital world.
And he's created this
new series of portraits
using only the emoji library
as a point of reference
to an individual that because
of his or her radical nature,
Adams feels is important to
American popular culture.
This specific work is of a woman
named Sister Souljah, which
some of you might
know is an author,
activist, and was known for
the Sister Souljah moment
during the Bill Clinton
presidential campaign.
So here, we have a
highly engaged artist
exploring the force of
popular culture and the media
on the perception and
construction of self-image
using emoji as a vehicle and a
whole new form of portraiture.
Next up, I looked
to Laura Owens--
the brilliant
female artist in LA,
who is known for her
large-scale paintings that
intertwine our
historical references
with painterly techniques.
I was fascinated by this
installation from 2015
in a club called The
Dirty Rag Soccer Club
Club in Chicago, which
is an exhibition space
in a former Polish soccer bar.
In it, Owens installed hundreds
of these emojis ceramic
sculptures above a
fully functional bar
opposite her paintings.
She made by hand 426
emoji sculptures.
And there are 383 of
them which are available,
if anybody wants to buy one.
Taking it one step further,
actually last November in 2017
to coincide with her
major retrospective
at the Whitney Museum, they
one-upped it and they cleverly
converted each of these emoji
into a free digital sticker
pack, which I love
and use incessantly.
In another example of
a contemporary artist
incorporating emoji, I
turned to Trevor Paglen--
the MacArthur
Genius prize winner
and previous artist-in-residence
at Stanford Cantor Arts Center.
Paglen is widely known for
an artistic practice which
seeks to expose and
investigate areas that
don't wish to be examined--
surveillance, military
operations, intelligence.
He played a crucial role with
Laura Poitras in "Citizenfour"
and his body of
work is currently
on show at the Smithsonian
in a major mid-career survey
exhibition.
This specific work, known
as the Symbology series,
looks at the totemic
visual language
inherent in military culture.
A typical uniform
will sport patches
identifying its wearer's
job, program affiliation,
achievements, and place
within that hierarchy.
These markers of
identity and program
heraldry begin to create a
very peculiar symbolic regime
when they depict one's
affiliation with what
the defense industry insiders
call the black world--
the world of classified
programs, projects,
and places, whose outlines
and even existence
are deeply-held secrets.
And finally, I turn to the
legendary John Baldessari,
who at 87 years old,
remains as forward thinking
as ever, known for using found
imagery that he recomposes
by carefully selecting pictures,
pairing them with text,
and often overlaying them with
large dots and swaths of color
to mask or bring attention
to the areas of detail.
For this series of paintings,
he focused on the animal emoji
specifically.
Taking this interest
in issues of context
and cultural
specificity further,
the new Emoji Series
evaluated the ubiquitous,
seemingly innocuous
images that we
use in everyday conversations.
And then this past
November, Baldessari
did a new Emoji Series.
Some of the text is
ironic and suggestive,
while some seem
completely random,
thus challenging the viewer to
make sense out of the pairings.
While emojis are indeed
straightforward images that
take the place of
their real-life words,
Baldessari's works
seem to suggest
that their meanings are not
actually set and are rather
subject to interpretation.
These universal images that
transcend cultural, social,
and linguistic
boundaries are easily
subverted when removed
from their iPhone context
and paired within
different text.
Even the hyper-bright white
background of the works
seems to recall the lighting
of the phone background
where these are typically
seen, thus making the artwork
itself represent something
beyond its material nature.
If you're curious,
the peaches sold out.
More recently, a couple of weeks
ago, the Prado Museum in Madrid
released its own bespoke
emoji via Twitter
to celebrate its
200th anniversary.
So if you #Prado200, you
immediately got this wonderful
Like button.
Segueing now from
the art world context
and into the unexpected
applications of emoji,
here you have an example of
actual text being translated
into emoji, which made me think
will Google Translate offer
that service?
The traditional
emoji nativity, which
went around and was widely
circulated during the holidays.
A portmanteau of emoji to
describe that sensation
many of us are currently
feeling back at work.
This is one of my favorites--
shopping by emoji.
Again, Zappos.
So if you go into
the Zappos app,
you can actually shop by emoji.
But unfortunately,
if you're a woman
who's looking for a flat shoe,
it's not readily visible.
However, the next
two screens do show
what you get when you put
in, say, the mermaid emoji
and the lips emoji.
I did contact Zappos.
They assured me
it's in there now.
So if you put in my
little flat shoe,
you get pages and
pages of ballet flats.
This is a page from the December
issue of "Elle" magazine,
again shopping for
your loved ones
based on their emoji usage.
I found this on Instagram.
This one also went viral, which
is quite fun and entertaining
looking at emoji usage on
a national country level.
And it began to make me think,
hmm, are emoji usage actually
sort of the national
psyche and what
does that mean for profiling?
There's the good aspect of emoji
targeting, like this endangered
species campaign.
And for those of
you that don't know,
you can actually buy emoji
usage data from Twitter
and then use it for your
marketing campaigns.
So while this is a fantastic
illustration of that tool,
another option is you're
sitting watching the Super Bowl,
and you're tweeting at your
friend that you're about
to order pizza, and you get a
discount code from Domino's.
And then the next week,
you get a discount code
for Jenny Craig for a
weight-loss program.
Another unexpected byproduct
of my emoji journey
was learning that at the
University of Michigan
within the art
history department,
there exists a class
for undergraduates
called Emoji Worlds.
It's taught by Joan Kee,
who has a PhD in art history
and a specialty in
Asian art contemporary,
but also has a JD
from Yale Law School.
And this class spends
about 12 weeks looking
at every aspect of emoji.
For their final
assignment, they were
each required to submit
an emoji proposal
and guaranteed an A-plus, by
the way, if it got adopted.
And with this image, I want
to finish on the significance
of design thinking.
Everything about this
crosswalk makes me smile.
It's insane.
And yet the design
and interpretation
of my emoji across
some platforms
was absolutely disheartening,
as though the intent
of the emoji at its very core
had been completely overlooked.
I'll let you guess which ones.
When John Baldessari was asked
about his new emoji series,
he once responded
that emoji to him
represented the most
democratic living language.
It is crowdsourced after all.
And that every time
you use one, you
are in essence casting a vote.
With that thought, I
wanted to point out
the design difference in the
newly-adopted brick emoji
and leave you to thinking about
what vote you are casting.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE UY: Thank you for coming to
Google and telling your story.
It's fascinating to me
every time I hear it.
So I mean, I really,
really appreciate it.
Thank you for
sharing that with us.
FLORIE HUTCHINSON:
It's my pleasure.
MIKE UY: I was going to ask
you which implementation?
I mean, you've been all over
with this emoji campaign.
Now that you see
it in real life,
which implementation are
you the happiest with?
I won't ask you which one
you don't like because I
think that was pretty obvious.
FLORIE HUTCHINSON:
I think the Apple
emoji was the truest to the
initial design I submitted.
It was Prussian blue, which
was a very considerate choice
to sort of flip on its head the
whole idea of blue is for boys,
pink is for girls.
One of the sort of
unexpected surprises
that I loved actually
about the Apple emoji
is that where all the
other shoes are actually
displayed at a
45-degree tilt, Apple
went further and truly made
it flat and horizontal,
which wasn't something
I had considered.
And yet, it really accentuates
the flatness of it.
I also loved that
within the Apple emoji
architecture and order,
the flat shoe actually
precedes the stiletto.
So when you scroll through
the apparel category,
the flat shoe is
the very first one.
And that made me smile a lot.
MIKE UY: That's great.
That's great.
Can you tell us a
little bit-- you told me
about how you actually went
about designing the flat shoe
emoji in the first place.
You spoke to an
artist friend and then
you had some very
specific requirements
of how you wanted it
drawn and why you wanted
it depicted it a certain way.
I thought it was
really interesting.
FLORIE HUTCHINSON:
So I reached out
to a graphic designer
named Aphee Messer, who
had been the illustrator for
the woman with a headscarf,
otherwise known as
the hijab emoji,
and coincidentally is also a
children's book illustrator.
And I thought she
would perfectly get
what I was trying to get at.
And my directors were
really quite open.
I absolutely wanted
it not to be pink,
so I said you can
choose the colors,
but it needs to
be gender neutral.
I wanted both options to be
available in terms of a flat
with a bow and one without.
Some people have asked me,
why did you include the bow?
It's such an overtly
feminine thing.
And the reality is in my
research of flat shoes,
all of the original
flats had that
binding to keep the shoe on.
And so it was
actually a reference
to the historical design of
flat shoes, which of course were
also woven by men.
And so I really wanted
the ultimate designers
to have the option of both
a flat with a bow and one
without.
And there were six color ways.
And I wanted the heel to be
as nonexistent as possible,
while still translating
on a microscale.
MIKE UY: So you submitted
several versions of this
to Unicode?
FLORIE HUTCHINSON: Yeah, so I
submitted two silhouettes-- one
with the bow and one without.
And each silhouette was
available in six colors,
which ranged from dark blue,
dark green, nude, brown, black.
MIKE UY: So it's fascinating
that you approached
the whole emoji proposal from
the art world perspective
because you're not in
tech, like everybody here.
And you taught yourself
how to propose to Unicode
and you wrote the whole
proposal yourself, right?
What was that like?
Where did you
start when you said
I wanted to get this emoji
accepted and adopted.
Did you even know there
was a Unicode organization
that you had to apply to?
And how did you how do you
start that whole journey?
FLORIE HUTCHINSON:
It was a really fun.
I get goosebumps
thinking about it
because I had an
excuse to get back
on sort of that student learning
curve and nerd out really.
And it all kind of
happened when no one
was looking in the
middle of the night
because until that red
stiletto autopopulated,
I had no idea how
emoji were made.
I literally held my
phone and I was like,
hmm, is Apple so smart
that this device has
some sort of mythic AI
that knows what my shopping
habits have been for the last
12 months, has aggregated that,
and therefore this
device knows that there's
a female holding this
phone and has predicted
that this is the stiletto--
that this is the
shoe emoji that's
going to resonate with me?
That was literally my
justification rationale.
And then I-- thank you, Google--
went down the
rabbit hole of how--
I literally typed in
"how do emoji get made?"
And that's when I lighted
on the most horrific Unicode
Consortium web page and
sort of navigated my way
through the like, how does
one submit a proposal.
And that's when my light
bulb moment went off,
which was, oh, wait a second.
Emoji are crowdsourced.
Anyone from me in Palo Alto
to an 85-year-old man in India
to a 15-year-old girl in
Berlin can submit a proposal.
They just need to fill
out this template.
And then once I realized that,
actually from a friend of mine
who's in the audience, I reached
out to the dumpling emoji
creator Jennifer 8.
Lee, and cold emailed
her from her website,
and said this is my idea.
This is my observation.
Am I crazy?
And with a matter of
hours, she came back to me
and very succinctly said,
this is a good idea.
The deadline is July 1st.
And so at this
point, it was June.
And I thought to myself,
OK, I've actually
vocalized this to someone.
I now have my marching
orders, no pun intended.
And I spent basically the next
three weeks putting together
the proposal entirely on my own.
And it was really fun.
The one thing that
I still think about
is if you go on the
Unicode website,
they make a point of
saying no emoji proposal
should be for "a
cause," quote unquote.
It will be dismissed.
There are some emoji
that get adopted,
however it's in spite of the
cause, not because of it.
And so one of the sort of lenses
that I was seeing my proposal
through was really trying
to downplay the cause
factor, which in fact, when
you look at that blue shoe
and you know me, you know it's
blatantly a cause-driven emoji.
And so I had to make it as
empirical and statistically
significant as possible.
And so I downplayed
the actual narrative
and made it about usage
adoption and creating
a really compelling
argument for it to be made.
MIKE UY: Fascinating,
fascinating.
So you're kind of all in
now-- you said you nerded out.
FLORIE HUTCHINSON: Yes.
MIKE UY: And you
love this process.
Some of us have
to do it for work,
but you love this process.
And you're not just stopping
with the flat-soled shoe emoji.
I've heard you've actually got
some other projects in the work
and not for women,
but men as well.
FLORIE HUTCHINSON: I do.
This past spring, I
coauthored a proposal
for a one-piece bathing suit
because the only swimwear
option right now is an itsy
bitsy, yellow, polka dot
bikini.
MIKE UY: Even for men?
FLORIE HUTCHINSON:
Even for men, which
is why the proposal
actually included
a one-piece swimsuit, a swim
trunk for men, and a swim brief
for men.
It's now been shortlisted.
MIKE UY: Oh, great.
So when do you hear about that?
FLORIE HUTCHINSON: I believe the
committee will vote in October.
And if all goes well, it will
roll out next year in 2020.
MIKE UY: Well, if
that happens, we'd
love to have you back here.
Maybe you could help.
So I don't know if you know
this, but the emoji sets--
like once Unicode decides the
emoji, how they're actually
depicted is up to each of the
companies, as you pointed out.
But there is a process
that we have at
Google that you could actually
get involved in if you wanted
to help do the Google version.
FLORIE HUTCHINSON:
100% count me in.
Where do I sign up?
MIKE UY: And thank you for
getting swim trunks out there
because every time
I text and like,
you know, bring your trunks,
I don't have an emoji.
FLORIE HUTCHINSON: Yeah.
Hopefully, you'll get one soon.
MIKE UY: That's great.
I wanted to get into
some of the other topics.
You said that you see emoji
as more than just as art.
It's become language.
And you touched on
it a little bit,
but we've had a
longer conversations
about how you see emoji
becoming part of linguistics.
I was wondering if
you'd comment on
that because that was
really fascinating, now
that your kids are growing up.
FLORIE HUTCHINSON: Well,
I'm not an academic,
but there is a term known
as elocutionary text.
And so sort of thinking back
to when the original emoji set
were introduced,
emoji were really
meant to be that
aspect which got
lost in electronic messaging of
the nonverbal-- so emotional,
facial, nonverbal
cues, intonation.
And you were able
to supplement sort
of just the purely textual
with the nonverbal cues
through an image.
And I find that
really interesting
because now when we
look at emoji usage,
they don't necessarily
replace words,
but they certainly
add the meaning
and the practical
meaning of a sentence.
And so some would say it's
part of the linguistic channel
of communication is
these nonverbal cues
that you can now
include pictorially.
And so to me, it's one of
those really interesting things
in that also, I mean,
there is a reason
the cliche "a picture is worth
a thousand words" exists.
And I've been thinking
a lot about how
certain emoji can be a time
capsule in and of themselves.
I mean, one of the things
that I didn't cover at all
is while my emoji
escapades were happening,
a lot of other greater
cultural things were happening.
I had my realization
moment in May 2017.
And basically three months
later in August, Melania Trump
tiptoed on her stilettos
to Hurricane Harvey, which
set the whole media furor.
And then a month later, the
Harvey Weinstein Me Too thing
happened, which again
changed the dialogue forever,
I'd like to think.
And then in January of 2018,
you had Time's Up happening
during the Oscars.
So that was a year ago.
And then in May, you had
the Cannes Film Festival,
where literally Kirsten
Stewart and a whole bunch
of A-list actresses were
removing their shoes
to walk the red carpet.
And so I'd like to think
that 30 years from now
when my kids are still seeing
at that little flat shoe emoji,
that they can sort of pinpoint
exactly what was happening
on a broader cultural level.
In the same group of the emoji
that mine was released in
is the mosquito emoji,
which to someone
who doesn't know the
context of that proposal,
they might think why do
I need a mosquito emoji.
But then when you
drill down, you
realize that was proposed by
a team from the Johns Hopkins
infectiology team and the Bill
& Melinda Gates Foundation.
And you suddenly realize
that that mosquito
is there for the purpose of mass
instant global communication
and thinking about how do you
communicate across countries
where maybe populations
aren't literate,
but completely understand
this image of a mosquito being
the vehicle by which
disease is transmitted?
Again, I think in a way, this
brick emoji and the brick wall
will immediately point
to a specific moment
in history and debate.
And so it's interesting to
me that these little images
can actually point to
historically-significant
moments if you know
the backstory to them.
MIKE UY: Hmm.
So my one last question,
and then we'll open it up
to everybody here and online.
But from that
perspective of history,
there is a lot of criticism
that the emoji library
has gotten too large.
And even on our team
in Android messages,
we're thinking of
new ways to let
people search and browse
emoji because it's
gone from the original
400 to over 2,700.
And there's talk about
should some emoji
be retired or replaced?
From the perspective of history,
what are your thoughts on that?
Should emoji be retired?
FLORIE HUTCHINSON:
It's a tricky one
because I can see the
unwieldiness argument,
but I also am not one
to use that argument
to justify retiring some.
Whenever the sort of quantity
argument comes into play,
I point to the fact that there
are like 13 phases of the moon
emoji.
Do we need 13 of them?
Probably not, but then
it becomes a point
of view decision-making matrix.
And so I would hate to
think that the minority
voice or the quietest
emoji would get
retired because its
usage or adoption
rate is lower than the
twinning Playboy bunnies.
So I think that's a bigger
question for the engineers
in the room to tackle.
but you know, like
I think there's
some statistic that by the
time a kid is five years old,
they've used and
heard 40,000 words.
So in the context
of 2,200 emoji,
yes, it's a bit unwieldy
to scroll through and find
the ones that are part
of your daily vocabulary,
but work harder.
MIKE UY: Thank you.
That's great.
All right, I'm going
to grab this mike.
AUDIENCE: How did
you put it out there
and how did it start
to go viral in the way
that it ultimately did?
FLORIE HUTCHINSON: So I came
up with the idea for the emoji
in May of 2017.
I sat on it for
a couple of days.
And then while going to an event
at the pop up magazine in San
Francisco, I floated it past
a very close friend, who said,
you should do it.
You've got nothing to lose.
And I was like, OK.
And then because I thought,
oh, well, you know,
Apple is the one
that dictates emoji,
I turned to a friend of mine
who worked at Apple and said,
can you introduce me to
someone on the design team
so that I can talk to
them about this stiletto.
And she was like,
well, actually,
Apple doesn't determine emoji.
The Unicode Consortium does.
And so that's when I taught
myself how to do the proposal.
I submitted it without really
telling many people that I did.
It was one of those things,
like college applications.
You don't really
want to tell people
where you've applied
because you don't
want to have deal
with like telling them
that you didn't get in.
And so there are a
few close friends
who knew that I was going
through the process.
When I got wind that it
was getting shortlisted,
I decided to contact a friend
of mine who happened to have
written a huge piece two years
prior in "The Atlantic"--
and had gone to college
with me-- on stilettos.
And I called her up
and I said, I just
want you to know I'm going
through this process.
I don't know whether it
will get accepted or not,
but I thought given
that you've allocated
this much ink to
stilettos in the past,
you might find this funny.
And she immediately got
back to me and was like,
I want to write about this.
Can I interview you?
And I said, sure, why not?
So that was in August
after the shortlisting.
And we agreed to
time the release
of that article in "The
Atlantic" to the Friday
before the Unicode committee
would be voting on the Monday.
What I didn't expect is that
between that Friday morning
and the Monday that "New York
Magazine" would basically
syndicate "The Atlantic"
piece, that it would become
the most-read piece
for the next 36 hours
on all of "New York
Magazine's" website
and most-shared article, and
that every single other outlet
would call me on
the Monday morning.
And so by the time the committee
met Monday afternoon to vote,
they literally I
think probably felt
like they had no
choice but to face
the wrath of a million
women who suddenly felt
this desperate need to have
a flat-soled shoe emoji, even
though they'd never
realized until that
moment, its omission.
And that's one of
the sort of feedback
that I got also with
the swimsuit emoji
when that sort of went
out in the public domain
was I was speaking to a
journalist at "The Times"
in the UK.
And she said, you know, the day
after the chief fashion critic
of "The New York Times"
wrote a huge piece
about the swimsuit emoji,
our entire editorial team
got together and said,
how did we miss this?
How did none of us realize that
the bikini is the only one?
And I think that's the thing
where emoji can course-correct,
in that you've got this
incredible ability in a fairly
quick timeline--
I mean, 18 months
from start to finish--
to enrich this vocabulary.
I mean, we're not talking
about legislation,
which can get bogged
down through 20
years of bureaucracy.
We're talking about a
world that it prides itself
on its agility to act fast.
So that was how we did it.
We bullied them into it.
Thank you, media.
MIKE UY: You ran a very
successful media campaign.
You didn't bully anybody.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What are your
thoughts on the inconsistencies
of the depiction of the
emoji submitted to Unicode
on the various platforms?
Obviously, like Apple,
Google, and Facebook
all have wildly different
depictions of the shoe.
Can you talk more
about your thoughts
and what you'd recommend, if
fragmentation is a good thing
or if you'd prefer consistency
in your next emoji submission?
FLORIE HUTCHINSON:
I hate the fact
that they're all different.
To me, it's oxymoronic
because emoji
are supposed to be instantly
recognizable between all
the platforms.
I would love nothing more than
to see it consistently applied.
That said, I recognize
that platforms
have a very distinct visual
and aesthetic language.
And so, you know,
Google has its own sort
of visual language versus Apple.
And it would be
ridiculous for me
to expect them to
somehow coordinate across
platforms and agree in
a consensus-style format
to one singular design.
I do think it's really funny
to think about how the design
aspect is rolled out.
I don't know if
you've noticed, say,
the jacket emoji
on Apple platform
looks eerily like a
Burberry trench coat.
And then you think
about the fact
that Angela Ahrendts was the CEO
of Burberry for over a decade
and is now in charge of
merchandising in Apple.
And you think, oh,
OK, I get this.
And so that jacket looks totally
different on Apple and Twitter.
And so it kind of to me
defies the very intent
behind emoji, which is I
send my flat shoe to someone
in Jaipur who uses a Samsung.
To me, those should
be the same images.
But again, I think that's a
coding and a brand problem
rather than--
in an ideal world,
it would be one.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to ask your opinion
on I've heard the argument that
emojis are actually taking us
back, evolutionarily
speaking, linguistically
to hieroglyphics, and that
it's a reductionist form
of language, and actually the
word-form language actually
allows us to
communicate more freely.
So I just didn't
know do you feel
like there is a parallel
between hieroglyphics
FLORIE HUTCHINSON: Absolutely.
I think emoji are
just hieroglyphs 2.0
in terms of pictorial language.
I think the main difference
though is obviously,
hieroglyphs were
created before words
existed in sort of
the traditional,
as we know it sense.
And I think in a way, if
you look at that slide
where they literally translated
Moby Dick into emoji,
no one is using
emoji in that way.
Whether it reduces sort
of vocabulary acquisition,
that's certainly
a concern of mine.
And it was actually
a conversation
I had with a journalist
from "Newsweek,"
who said, do you know of any
linguists or sort of language
acquisition specialists
in childhood
who could talk to me
about sort of the downside
or the effects of emoji
on young brains in 0 to 5
because we learn
80% of what we're
going to know our whole
life in that age group.
And I said, no, you
know, it's such a nascent
and embryonic state,
but no one has actually
done the research yet.
I think about the fact
that for our generation,
screen time-- is it
going to be like tobacco
the generation before?
We're all using it and
thinking it's fine.
And 20 years from now, all of
the studies and researchers
are going to come out and be
like, how did you miss this?
How did you not notice
the nefarious effect
of these things on you?
And so I do wonder
whether children--
our children-- in
20, 30 year's time
are going to get the results
from all those academic studies
that show that emoji
usage, screen time literacy
rates are plummeting.
I'm optimistic and I'd like to
think that it won't, but I'm
not an academic in that field.
I think it takes a sociologist
to figure that one out.
MIKE UY: After the
swimsuit emoji,
is there anything else
top of mind or anything
else you plan to work on?
Is this going to become
like a side career for you?
FLORIE HUTCHINSON: I don't know.
There are a couple of
things that have been
sort of percolating in my head.
One obvious one, which I think
would be kind of a coding
nightmare, is that
obviously, the family emoji
stop at two kids.
And clearly, I need
more than that.
So I'd love to see an emoji that
has two parents with four kids
and maybe get large families
lobbying for it with me.
Another one, which
again, I think
is reflective of my worldview
is the play category
is completely missing.
There aren't any slides.
There aren't any swings.
There aren't any seesaws,
which are very much
part of my weekend existence.
And certainly, I've
been thinking a lot
about the sort of
natural disaster
and natural catastrophe
category, which was sort of
inspired by the mosquito emoji.
And that if we're going
to use these little images
to communicate on a broad,
massive, instantaneous level,
can't we use it to alert
people to an earthquake,
alert people to a tornado,
alert people to a hurricane,
and in one little
image, get people
evacuating quickly rather than
going through the Amber Alert
System, for example?
It's exciting, but one of the
things that does sort of keep
me up is this idea of emoji
usage eventually being mined
and used to profile people.
You know, like if
you use the fist bump
and it's of a dark-skin
tone, will that
register you in some
capacity at an agency
and lump you into one box?
And so I think if I do another
emoji, it has to be important.
Like to me, the shoe
emoji was never about,
oh, I just want a shoe emoji.
It was about everything else.
And I think it's easy to
lose sight of that intent,
if you don't know the backstory.
But I say that, and yet I was
on the Unicode page last week
and I noticed in the shortlisted
list was an emoji proposal
for fondue, which as someone who
is half Swiss, they designed it
with a little
[INAUDIBLE],, which is
a traditional sort
of copper-orange pot
handle with the two sticks.
And I loved it, you know.
Like the levity aspect
is one of the things
I think that makes emoji
so attractive and fun.
And I was like, yes, I
hope it makes it because I
want that fondue emoji.
So you need to balance the two.
MIKE UY: Well,
thank you very much.
You're certainly welcome
back here anytime at Google.
FLORIE HUTCHINSON: Thank you.
MIKE UY: And we'd love
to hear more if there's
other emoji that get approved.
We'll certainly be
tracking them as well,
but thank you very much.
FLORIE HUTCHINSON: Great.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]